durchbruch vermeldeten die
nachrichtenagenturen vor knapp einer
stunde das klimaschutzpaket steht nach
einem wahren verhandlungsmarathon die
ganze nacht durch hatten sich die
spitzen von cdu csu und spd um die ohren
geschlagen um letzte steine aus dem weg
zu räumen
am nachmittag soll jetzt das klima
kabinett die beschlüsse auf den weg
bringen es sollte ein paket werden wie
es deutschland beim klimaschutz noch
nicht gesehen hat aber hat das geklappt
und was bedeuten die maßnahmen für die
bürger wir blicken jetzt ausführlich auf
das thema und beginnen mit dem harten
ringen andreas künast
diese nacht wird deutschland auf jahre
verändern und wenn alles nach plan läuft
den heimatplaneten auch in berlin
entscheidet die regierung wie europas
mächtigste volkswirtschaft den ausstoß
von treibhausgasen um 55 prozent senken
kann bis 2030 dafür soll co2 teurer
werden aber nicht über eine steuer
sondern über den handel mit zertifikaten
wir haben eine gemeinsame sichtweise in
der koalition die heißt die bepreisung
von co2 wird ein wichtiger baustein in
diesem gesamtkonzept sein während sich
die mitarbeiter die zeit vertreiben
hatten die spitzen der gruppe zunächst
die unstrittigen pläne ab neben hohen
kosten soll der klimaplan auch anreize
schaffen sollen klimafreundliche
sanierungen wie neue fenster besser
gefördert werden sollen bahn tickets
günstiger werden wird eine abwrackprämie
für ölheizungen eingeführt für ein paar
stunden rufen die parteispitzen
fachminister wie die umweltministerin
dazu viele details sind umstritten wie
der ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
wir müssen parallel dazu den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien auf 65 prozent bis
zum jahre 2030 gewährleisten weil wir
können uns den kohleausstieg
beispielsweise schenken wenn wir keine
alternativen energiequellen erschließen
als am morgen die ersten demonstranten
da sind fällt auf dass viele minister
diesmal nicht mit limousine gefilmt
werden wollen sondern zu fuß kommen oder
per rad es scheint nicht oft zu
passieren so angestrengt klimafreundlich
sich die deutsche politik heute
inszeniert es bleibt die frage reicht
das aus nein das ist jetzt der beginn
eines marathonlaufs ich würde mal sagen
wenn das heute erfolgreich ist dann ist
das vielleicht gerade mal die wegmarke
fünf kilometer von 42 wir reden nächstes
jahr ja schon darüber dass wir bei der
großen klimakonferenz europa seine ziele
erhöhen will
und wenn europa das ziel erhöht dann
wird auch deutschland wieder mehr tun dh
wir werden nächstes jahr schon wieder
darüber reden was das nächste klimapaket
sein kann nach 19 stunden verhandlungen
verlassen die ersten parteichefs das
kanzleramt beschlossen sind eine höhere
pendlerpauschale das verbot alter
heizungen und keine neuverschuldung des
klimas wegen noch sind nicht alle
ergebnisse bekannt noch sind die
erwartungen riesig
ja und das harte ringen hat die ganze
zeit unser hauptstadtkorrespondenten
chuck und sarah bahn ag verfolgt guten
tag und allah wir haben schon ein paar
sachen gehört die jetzt klar sind was im
klimaschutz paket stehen wird was ist
sonst noch über die einigung bekannt
also die einigung ist da und es kommen
jetzt nach und nach erste informationen
raus und 13.15 soll das klima kabinett
tagen und sich dann noch mal endgültig
über den beschluss beugen
es soll auf jeden fall eine einigung auf
eine co2 preisen geben die in mehreren
schritten erfolgt desto schon mit einem
niedrigen co2 preis beginnen über eine
co2 steuer das hören wir hier so aus der
runde
und dann später mit einem
emissionshandel weitergehen die details
da sind wir jetzt sehr gespannt darauf
wie das funktionieren soll und wie sich
das tatsächlich im einzelnen abspielt
auch bei den kosten soll es eine
einigung geben die höher liegt als das
was man bisher immer gehört hatte
bis 2023 angeblich ohne neuverschuldung
durchgerechnet auch da müssen wir jetzt
mal ganz genau hinschauen welche zahlen
ist dann gibt um 14.30 soll es eine
pressekonferenz geben und da wird es
dann wahrscheinlich etwas klarer was
genau heute nach beschlossen worden ist
okay es ist noch vieles offen wir haben
es auch jetzt gerade noch von ihnen noch
mal gehört das klimaschutzpaket ist er
wirklich ganz frisch erst raus kann man
dann trotzdem schon so erkennen ob es
eher die handschrift der union oder der
spd trägt also was man schon sagen kann
ist dass beide ihre handschrift
hinterlassen haben wie genau das rennen
dann am ende ausgeht wer dafür sich das
meiste reklamieren kann das können wir
erst sagen wenn wir das papier
tatsächlich in der hand haben aber es
gibt auf jeden fall schon mal die eine
million ladestellen die von herrn steuer
einmal vorgeschlagen worden sind für die
e-autos es gibt eine prämie für den kauf
von e-autos unter 40.000 euro und auf
der anderen seite jetzt muss ich mal
gerade auf meinem blatt gucken gibt es
hier auch massive förderungen zum
beispiel für die umstellung von von
ölheizung auf klimafreundlichere
energieträger bei der wärme aber die spd
zum beispiel wird sicherlich für sich
reklamieren dass sie es geschafft hat
einen kontrollmechanismus in das papier
mit rein zu verhandeln das hat sie immer
gefordert die fortschritte und
vielleicht auch das zurückbleiben hinter
den zielen sollen regelmäßig überprüft
werden und das hören wir hier sei in
diesem beschluss auch mit drin also
beide werden sicherlich am ende sagen
wir haben vieles durch bekommen wir
müssen
am ende einer ganz genau anschauen wie
viel es tatsächlich ist vielen dank für
diese erste einschätzung schack und
alabama die über das klimaschutzpaket
auf das sich die große koalition jetzt
geeinigt hat und wir hören schon im
hintergrund die fische es gibt eine demo
von fridays for future in berlin und
mitten in der demo und damit gehen wir
weiter zu unserem nächsten
gesprächspartner steht anton hofreiter
er ist fraktionsvorsitzender im
bundestag vom bund ist 90 bündnis 90/die
grünen guten tag herr hofreiter
guten tag herr hofreiter die opposition
ist ja naturgemäß kritisch was die
regierungsarbeit angeht aber nach allem
was ihnen bisher über das
klimaschutzpaket bekannt ist ist das der
große wo unser maßstab ist somit dem
klimaschutzpaket die ziele von paris
eingehalten werden können
und nach allem was wir bis jetzt wissen
werden die ziele von paris mit diesem
klimaschutzpaket verfehlt deshalb sie
haben wir es gemacht aber sie haben das
eigentliche ziel verfehlt gut was fehlt
denn dann ihrer meinung nach wie könnten
die klimaziele eingehalten werden was
müsste da drinstehen dem paket
man müsste zb mutiger sein beim co2
preis wenn es wirklich stimmt dass der
erst 21 kommt mit unter 30 euro starten
soll
dann hat es keine lenkungswirkung oder
auch insgesamt muss man sagen beim
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien müsste
man noch mal mutiger vorangehen um
wirklich die ziele einzuhalten
die große koalition will für das
klimaschutzpaket auf jeden fall keine
schulden aufnehmen
die schwarze null die steht ist das denn
richtig ihrer meinung die große
koalition den gigantischen ökologische
schulden seit vielen jahren auf weil sie
seit 14 jahren nicht gehandelt hat und
am ende wird entscheidend sein dass
unsere kinder und kindeskinder einen
lebenswerten planeten bekommen deswegen
ist die schwarze null ein fehlerhaftes
ziel und das richtige ist die rettung
unserer lebensgrundlagen
aber wie viel geld wollen sie dafür in
die hand nehmen die kommenden
generationen müssten das ja dann auch
alles bezahlen
wenn die kommenden generationen keinen
funktionsfähigen planeten mehr haben
dann ist vieles andere mehr als
problematisch und wir sind der meinung
dass oben eine investitions regel die
schuldenbremse erweitert werden soll
und wir werden dafür neue investitionen
36 milliarden euro
als rahmen in die hand nehmen damit
könnte man sehr sehr viele dinge
ermöglichen
das würde auch der wirtschaft gut tun
dass wir eine win win situation
vielen dank für das gespräch das war
anton hofreiter fraktionsvorsitzender
von bündnis 90/die grünen im bundestag
fehler kritisches gespräch von der
freude ist future demo in berlin
ja wir haben die demonstranten schon im
hintergrund gesehen in deutschland sind
im bundesweit demonstrationen von files
für feature und weltweit spüren
politiker den druck der straße was den
klimaschutz angeht so haben die
aktivisten von feines verfügte heute
international eine streikwoche begonnen
er mehrheit 2000 städten soll es
demonstrationen geben
allein in australien streiten bereits
300.000 kinder eltern und unterstützer
wie hier in brisbane
es müsse sofort gehandelt werden um den
klimawandel aufzuhalten heißt es anlass
der streikwoche ist der un-klimagipfel
der kommende woche stattfinden soll und
in deutschland hoffen weil es für future
zudem dem klima klima kabinette was er
derzeit tag vorher unterm hintern machen
zu können am mittag haben wir die
proteste zehntausender begonnen unser
reporter waren in drei städten unterwegs
und haben mit demonstranten gesprochen
in berlin begannen die proteste bereits
im herbst vor dem
bundesfinanzministerium versammelte sich
die initiative entrepreneurship und 3600
unternehmen in deutschland gehören dazu
sie unterstützen den streikaufruf der
schüler wir haben uns für einen komplett
streik entschieden bei services
das heißt wir schließen unseren online
shop für 24 stunden alle und dann unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
bekommen einen sonder urlaubstag es für
uns eine selbstverständlichkeit dass
unsere mitarbeiter heute freigestellt
werden hier hergekommen können wir
halten es für extrem wichtig dass die
wirtschaft zeigt wir sind bereit auch
nachteile in kauf zu nehmen deshalb
haben heute zu gemacht das ist hoher
umsatzverlust im fünfstelligen bereich
die haupt demo begann um 12 am
brandenburger tor
10.000 teilnehmer sind angemeldet
darunter längst nicht mehr nur schüler
das finde ich super wichtig weil wir
halt teil der gesellschaft der
menschheit sind und es betrifft uns alle
nicht nur die kinder
ich denke diese ganze bewegung ist das
erste seit den 80er 90er jahren wieder
eine große volksbewegung zusätzlich sind
in berlin im laufe des tages immer
wieder spontan demos angekündigt bis hin
zu straßenblockaden hannover heute
mittag langsam nimmt der protest auch
hier fahrt auf ganze schulklassen sind
auf der straße und eltern mit ihren
kindern heute schon vor zu meiner
schulzeit am besten anfangen sollen und
jetzt brennt es an allen ecken und enden
versuchen ganz fehler plastik auf
verpackungsmüll zu verzichten gerade
beim einkauf versuchen möglichst
ökologische putzmittel zum beispiel zu
verwenden
die schüler der kgs barsinghausen haben
heute morgen ganz spontan ihren lehrer
vom protest überzeugt also das was
bringt so dass die menschen von mir aus
mehr fahrrad fahren oder zu fuß gehen
ich glaube dass die politiker und
erwachsene lange nicht zugehört haben
aber ich glaube dass es langsam erzählt
wird dass die erwachsenen endlich mal
seit wenigen minuten sind die
demonstranten auf dem weg richtung
innenstadt die veranstalter rechnen mit
rund 8.000 teilnehmern die dresdnerin
laura kaiser hat von ihrer schule heute
frei bekommen damit sie hier sein kann
am hauptbahnhof an einem der beiden
startpunkte der demos das anliegen wir
von freies for future möchten dass die
politik jetzt endlich konkrete maßnahmen
auf den tisch legt das endlich fakten
geschaffen werden und dass es nicht noch
jahrzehnte weiter einfach verschwiegen
wird und der nächsten generation die
verantwortung stillschweigend übertragen
wird
thema in sachsen der ausstieg aus der
braunkohle derzeit anvisiert für 2008
und 30
es reicht uns nicht aus wir müssen jetzt
anfangen sozial kohle ausstieg
vorzubereiten damit der bis 2030 noch
möglich ist dass klimaschutz das
tägliche zu tun von jedem verlangt
scheint hier konsens ich selbst meide
deswegen eben das fleisch zu hause fast
so gut dass es so viel wie möglich wie
es geht mit dem fahrrad zur gleichen
zeit am anderen sammelpunkt dresden
erwartet am frühen nachmittag mehrere
tausend teilnehmer
und wir wollen jetzt mal schauen was
eigentlich das klimaschutzpaket für die
bürger bedeutet und was bisher bekannt
ist wollen wir deshalb einordnen lassen
von einem der renommiertesten deutschen
klimaforscher vom professor ottmar
edenhofer direktor des potsdam institut
für klimafolgenforschung guten tag
professor eben hofer sonntag professor
edenhofer sie beraten ja auch die
bundesregierung in klimaschutzfragen wie
bewerten sie das was da jetzt auf dem
tisch liegt
wir wissen ja noch nicht ganz genau was
auf dem tisch liegt es sieht so aus als
wäre jetzt ein einstieg in die co2
preisen gelungen allerdings zu einem
sehr sehr niedrigen einstiegspreis der
wahrscheinlich am anfang relativ wenig
lenkungswirkung hat jetzt wird
entscheidend sein
was steht denn eigentlich in diesem
paket drin wie dieser preis sich über
die zeit hinweg entwickeln wird wir
wissen er muss steigen und zwar ziemlich
stark steigen bis zum jahr 2030 damit
wir überhaupt die europäischen
verpflichtungen erreichen können und wir
uns am ende die strafzahlungen an andere
europäische mitgliedsstaaten ersparen ob
das gelingt das kann ich bei dem
jetzigen stand der verhandlungen nichts
sagen da müssen wir noch ein bisschen
warten aber wenn das so in etwa das ist
was wir bislang hören dann ist das ein
anfang aber es reicht nicht aus und man
hatte das gefühl da wird einfach zu viel
auf die zukunft verlagert und zu wenige
entscheidungen heute gefällt haben sie
das gefühl diese entscheidung sind
verbindlich weil es soll ja auch so
einen prüfmechanismus geben wo man denkt
heißt das jetzt wieder dass die
klimaziele nicht sicher eingehalten
werden
das war ja von anfang an klar dass wenn
wir mit einer co2 bepreisung beginnen
dass man diese preise anpassen wird und
insofern ist ein solcher prüfmechanismus
sinnvoll und gut die frage ist natürlich
nur wieder genau ausgestaltet ist und
wie verpflichtend dann die empfehlungen
einer solchen expertengremiums sind und
aus meiner sicht wäre jetzt entscheidend
gewesen dass sich die bundesregierung
nicht nur zu einem einstiegspreis
verpflichtet sondern auch zu einem
ambitionierten preis pfad denn die
verbraucher und die investoren müssen
doch jetzt wissen was auf sie zukommt
bei den investitionsentscheidungen
genügt es ja nicht dass man eine
perspektive und einem jahr hat dann muss
man eine perspektive von fünf bis zehn
jahren haben und wenn das fehlt dann
werden hier keine sicherheiten
geschafften für die investoren sondern
eher unsicherheiten und das ist nicht
das was wir eigentlich empfohlen haben
und wollten
lassen wir mal ganz kurz konkret gucken
jetzt für was das für die menschen
bedeutet ab 2021 sollen benzin und
diesel um 3 prozent teurer werden
bis 2026 dann um 10 cent wie schätzen
sie das also ein auf was müssen sich die
bürger einstellen wird der preis immer
weiter steigen bis wohin
na ja der preis muss natürlich steigen
jetzt muss man sagen die zahlen die sie
genannt haben
das sind ja minimale anstiege das ist ja
schon fast die fluktuation der
weltmarktpreise für öl
das ist ja nichts was die bürger bisher
nicht zu verkraften gehabt hätten
vielleicht werden sie jetzt ein bisschen
stärker darauf reagieren weil sie wissen
der preis wird langfristig ansteigen
aber das sind doch sehr sehr moderate
einstiegspreise und ich habe er die
befürchtung dass wir die 2030 ziele
damit nicht erreicht
werden also vor dem hintergrund müssen
sich die bürger darauf größere
preissteigerungen einstellen wenn wir
diese ziele erreichen wollen aber das
ist auch möglich wenn im laufe der zeit
dann auch vermehrt innovationen auf den
markt kommen und vermehrt kostengünstige
alternativen zur verfügung stehen und
die regierung scheint er mit den
förderprogrammen das anzustreben dass
jetzt die alternativen entwickelt werden
die dann nach 2022 verstärkt auf dem
markt zur verfügung stehen soll
vielen dank für dieses interview
professor ottmar edenhofer direktor des
potsdam institut für
klimafolgenforschung dankeschön
ich danke ihnen und mehr zu dem thema
heute abend in einem zdf spezial
klimapaket der groko große wurf oder
heiße luft direkt im anschluss an die 19
uhr heute sendung